more than a dozen people left with
nowhere to go thanks for joining us here
at noon I'm Heather Mills a fire ripped
through this apartment complex early
this morning injuring several people
including a firefighter people on the
scene tell 8 news now some were forced
to jump from their balconies to escape
the Flames it happened at Charleston and
Torrey Pines just after five this
morning seven people are at UMC being
treated including a firefighter a next
door neighbor tells us they woke up to
sirens and smoke
come outside in the apartments in Flames
so
um I'm happy that fire department and
police came out quickly
a Las Vegas fire and rescue knocked out
the Flames within an hour 14 people
though are now displaced and they're
being helped by the Red Cross the cause
of the fire is under investigation